sort of already seeing a pretty active
fire season with neighboring states
especially Arizona fires that are
showing really extreme fire behavior
because we're so early in the fire
season
Kirsten Joyce joining us now with
details on our state Denice members of
the BLM u.s. Forest Service Nevada
Division of Forestry and Weather Service
got together on a recent zoom call to
discuss our state's seasonal outlook
they said we had a very dry winter
across much of the state and did not get
a whole lot of moisture to pack down
fuel loads from previous winters added
to that very little precipitation the
last 30 days and record-setting
temperatures already that have rapidly
dried out our lower level elevation
fuels well despite Cove in nineteen all
of the offices across the state are
staffed and prepared we are seeing
drought conditions and much of the state
it's looking to be an above average fire
season for the southern portion of the
state in June probably the latter part
of June though the southern portion of
the state has already been seeing quite
a lot of fire activity the rest of the
state will go into above normal
conditions likely for most of July this
year see CFD has a new utility vehicle
that can be deployed and hard to reach
desert areas fire crews started
practicing last month at the Spring
Mountain Ranch near Red Rock with it the
fire utility vehicle holds 70 gallons of
water five gallons of foam it's equipped
with 700 feet of hose it is normally
housed with the Clark County Fire
Training Center so that it may be
deployed countywide Ted here's -
thankfully there are no big fires being
reported in the entire state thankfully
that's all in Arizona like you just
mentioned and some in California too
however we've been seeing a lot of this
lately red flag warnings in effect right
now till 8 o'clock tonight what this
means is a combination again of the
gusty winds the low humidity creates an
elevated and high fire danger so outdoor
burning
please don't even think about in effect
8 o'clock tonight humidity to go up a
little for tomorrow that'll get us out
of that red flag fire warning we all